he's at it again part of a promotion for
a Scottish company in Davos but it's
hard not to hear a melancholic tune
after all by next year's World Economic
Forum Britain should officially be out
of the EU it's still not clear how so
the British Prime Minister canceled her
visit - you might see Prince William
cross your path he probably won't be
commenting on brexit though but others
like this top German economists are
speaking their minds the terrible thing
is that the EU is trying to find a way
to make Britain an offer for leaving
that doesn't make sense we want them to
stay in the EU we want them to be part
of it we have a historic opportunity to
turn the situation around the EU should
be making Britain an offer to stay if
brexit were off the table Europe could
finally concentrate on the future again
it would do well to act now so that it's
not left behind in competition with
China and the u.s. it's time to talk
about a new European economic policy in
the US consumer sector there's the
digital platform economy in China we see
how industry is rapidly digitizing and
one of the big issues here is what is
the future digital infrastructure for
European industry and Davos is of course
a forum where all that's being discussed
Europe will try to set the tone in Davos
this year even though everything is
being overshadowed by brexit
alright let's cross over to Davos and
our senior business editor Ben fazool
and standing by Ben the brexit conundrum
is on many people's minds at the Forum
and that's despite the political
deadlock that we're seeing in the UK
right now there seems to be some
progress tell us more yeah baby steps
are being made by Liam Fox the trade
minister who's basically trying to
replicate the --use trade deals with the
rest of the world for the UK and every
single other country in the world so
he's got a big job on his hands you know
Briggs it is just around the corner he's
only here for two days but what better
place to be there's no other conference
in the world where so many world leaders
are he's already done deals with
Australia and you
so there's the progress he's also got
South Korea on his agenda here Columbia
Canada Hong Kong and Israel he'll also
be meeting investors to try assure them
that things are going to run smoothly
come brexit in March and also he's
holding a roundtable of CEOs so I guess
he'd have to be the busiest man here in
Davos now then Europe is facing an array
of issues we have brexit on the one side
then there's a rise of populism people
questioning democracy how's the mood in
Davos in light of these developments
well there's going to be a special
address this afternoon from German
Chancellor Angela Merkel she'll be
talking about Europe today is Europe day
she'll be trying to assure countries
that they need to look outwards not just
in words whether on that message comes
across is is a good question
I don't know CEOs would like to see that
it as well I mean it means that trade
will flourish it means that they'll have
better business of course I was talking
to one entrepreneur who said that brexit
is a disaster for him he's got hundreds
of jobs on the line because he just does
not know what's going to happen
he's got legal costs which are hurting
and this is the situation for many
people here and then tech is a big issue
at Davos every year give us the latest
that you know on bio-hybrid robotics
what is that a good question the cyborgs
are basically already here this is 3d
printed parts that use living animal
tissue to create limbs and body parts at
the moment they're using muscle tissue
from rats and sea slugs but they hope at
some stage to use human tissue and
basically yeah for people who are
missing a finger or a limb there you go
you become a cyborg doesn't it sound
exciting it does certainly DW senior
business editor Ben fazil own reporting
from Davos Ben thank you so much now the
opening day of the Davos meeting many
eyes were on Brazil's nearly elected
president Jair balsa Niro
in a shorter than expected keynote
address the far-right politician tried
to sell his new Brazil concept hoping to
drum up business business for the
country's ailing economy Boston ro told
the World Economic Forum he's opening up
Brazil for business
he promised to fight corruption invest
in security and cut taxes to boost
production and generate employment we
want to show that Brazil is taking
measures so that the world reestablishes
confidence in us that the business will
once again flourish between Brazil and
the rest of the world without being
guided by ideology we'll show the world
that we're countries safe for
investments especially in the area of
agribusiness which is very important to
us the meeting is the first
international outing for Brazil's new
president top economists are surprised
about his popularity at Davos it's
ironic that the there over sessions with
autocrats dominate and you can't get
into them at a place like this yet at a
time when autocratic strongmen dominate
the world's political stage this year's
Davos gives Boston ro an air of
legitimacy
you